Bộ phía nguồn khá khu bíng hình này là chỉ em không biết tự trào hỏi khi khách đến nhà.
Một lời trào tưởng trường đứng dạng, nhưng không thực hiện đúng lúc.
Thì bị sếm là thiếu lệ phép, khi những ngày còn được dịch nhận nghiêm足.
Có ngình dăng được nước ra là gió chá mẹ thay cô không dạ học sinh.
Tôi đọc năm cũng sắp đào đức của tiểu học thì không thấy có nổi dung này.
Trong sắp đào đức, một nămu trín chếm ba, tại vài vì ba có dạy nổi dung,
lệ phép trào hỏi người lớn, gần chào bạn có thể cô chào ông bà cho mẹ chào khách đến nhà.
Bì vậy tôi đang ngày thần phố cho thi đyểm, đưa nổi dung dạy chế biết chào người lớn và nổi dung trung trình giá được phố thông vụ xung lúc mục.
Thầ cô và chào mẹ phố hợp cũng ngắn chế, để học đi đối với hành.
Nếu việc này giết chế lệ phép hơn khi kìa người lớn thì bò dù được gào tạo,
các thẻ cập nhật nổi dung này và sất đào đức lúc mục hiện hành.